[Music]
alright let's get started hi everyone my
name is Jacob bank I'm the product lead
for Gmail and I'm going to be presenting
along with Ian leader who's here in the
front row he's the product lead for
Google Calendar and we're going to be
talking about time we're going to do a
little hero-villain routine I'm going to
be the villain that's going to utterly
depressed all of us about by explaining
a bunch of reasons why we're terrible at
managing our time and I hopeless the
situation is and then IANS going to be
the hero who comes saves us and tell us
about all the features we're building
into email calendar they're trying to
take these behavioral flaws and mistakes
into account in the way we design
products to help people spend their time
as well as they can so we'll start with
an obligatory groan inducing cliche time
is precious but as we all collectively
roll our eyes it's worth spending a
moment to think about why time is
actually pretty unique as a resource and
why it's particularly difficult
difficult to manage because of these
unique properties you can't really save
it you can't really make more of it and
let you be like a barrel of kale every
day all you can do is spend it as wisely
as possible once it's spent it's gone
and some exercise that I go through
about once and ones that I'd recommend
all of you go through if not now in real
time maybe after the session ends over
lunch think about the three most
important things you want to accomplish
this year then look back at your
calendar for the last week two weeks and
try to figure out how much time you
actually spent on those three most
important things you're anything like me
it'll be a terrifyingly small amount of
time that you spent on the three things
that are actually important to you
whether it's in your personal life or
your professional life and more
generally you can do a more general
exercise where you draw a pie chart of
where your time is going now and a pie
chart of where you'd like your time to
go and there probably be a scary
mismatch between those two and it's not
just us it's actually been studied a
bunch McKinsey did a study a few years
ago where they interviewed a bunch of
executives and ask them how satisfied
they were with the way they manage their
time only nine percent said that they
were very satisfied with the way that
they manage their time and only 52
percent
said that the way they spent their time
largely matched their organization's
strategic priorities so while we spend
hours an hour tackling about do we
launched this feature or that feature
can we save a penny here can we save a
nickel there we're maybe missing out an
opportunity to save half of the time
that we're currently not putting towards
our strategic priorities and line it up
better with our goals so where does that
time actually go McKenzie did another
study a couple years ago on how a
typical knowledge worker spends their
day and here are the results for the
average knowledge worker about 20% of
their time reading and answering email
alone it's almost three hours in a
typical 40-hour workweek 19% of their
time searching and gathering information
14 percent collaborating internally
meetings and 39% on role specific tasks
aka the real work that these people were
all hired to do only 39 percent of their
time spent on real work so we're going
to do in this talk what my portion of
the talk I'm going to go through a bunch
of mistakes that people make in dealing
with their email and in dealing with
their schedules and cite some research
from behavioral psychology and
behavioral economics that helps to
explain why our brains are wired to be
bad at using these tools to make
decisions about how we spend our time
start with email the first and probably
most debilitating flaw we face in
dealing with our email is that it's a
constant source of interruption typical
knowledge worker gets about 120 emails a
day but what is it actually what does
that cost in terms of interrupts I'd
like maybe I just checked my phone
quickly put it back in my pocket no harm
done turns out there's actually been a
research group that spent years studying
specifically email interruptions in the
workplace and what the cost of those
interruptions is and what they found is
that when you actually open your email
client from doing a creative tasks like
writing a paper or preparing a
presentation the average cost of that
interruption is 25 minutes it's a pretty
striking number and it's going to sound
crazy but if you actually think through
some of these scenarios it'll probably
start to resonate so you get a
notification on your phone
oh that's my boss I got a reply to that
you open up your email client you
realize if they're asking for some
number that you don't have to top have
off the top of your head you go to some
dashboard you find the number you
compose a well-crafted email you fire it
off to your boss by that time another
email has come in that you need to reply
to repeat the same routine again
then someone sent you like a video of a
dog skateboarding on a Christmas tree
you got to go watch that and then in a
moment of panic you realize that you
actually need to go back to writing your
paper or preparing your presentation
wherever the important creative task is
that you were doing by that point you've
forgotten what slide you were working on
or what paragraph you were writing and
what your train of thought was and you
have to re-establish all of that mental
state before you can continue to be
creative and you get a number that's
kind of like 25 minutes so these
interruptions are extremely costly
because we get distracted very easily
second flaw procrastination this is one
we've all heard experienced it's talked
about a lot usually people's mental
model of procrastination is like a
college student stays up all night
eating pizza and playing video games
instead of working on their term paper
but they're actually much more subtle
and devious forms of procrastination
that plague us throughout the workday
and that's typically when we do easy
things that make us feel productive and
give us a quick win but aren't actually
contributing to our long-term
productivity or or strategic goals and a
lot of this happens in email it's a lot
easier and feels a lot more productive
to read a mailing list reply to an email
címon on a thread that totally doesn't
need our opinion rather than doing the
hard work of producing a document or a
presentation or the kind of creative
work that taxes are our cognitive
capacity we just can't resist an easy
win and as a result we don't spend
nearly enough time on the hard but
important stuff third anyone heard of
Eisenhower's matrix the Eisenhower
matrix it's like you make a 2x2 grid and
you put urgency on one axis and
importance on the other axis and clearly
stuff that's both urgent and important
you should do all that stuff first
clearly stuff that's neither important
or urgent you should never do and then
the buckets where people make a lot of
mistakes are
do things that are urgent but not
important over things that are important
but not urgent and the case of email
similar to the procrastination example a
lot of emails we probably all seen
emails that have a subsonic urgent
please read urgent action required
depends how we define urgency but how
many of those are actually urgent like
if you don't reply this second the world
that's going to explode probably not
many of them and it's that same research
group that I mentioned but snot a lot of
work on email interruption has also
studied email backing behavior and it
turns out that if you do fewer sessions
in email a day like three long sessions
where you deal with all of your email
instead of fifty short sessions where
you deal with only one email a time
you're both more productive and less
stressed but again it's very hard for us
to resist that urgent please read urgent
please reply even when it's not actually
urgent and we should be doing our
important work instead forth our
inability to say no how many of us have
ever received an email where someone
else is asking us to do something
probably all of us probably you all have
like 10 in your inbox right now saying
no is really hard because social
conventions dictate that we need to come
up with a really really good excuse that
makes us and the requester feel
comfortable about the rejection of their
request and the cognitive load of making
these excuses is so high that we often
think I might as well just just do the
thing rather than making the excuse but
rarely is that actually the smart choice
in terms of time management and
prioritization and because of this
social convention that makes it very
tough very hard for us to say no the
result is that people set our priorities
for us like a lot of people have said
things like an email is like a to-do
list that other people write - and it's
true largely because of this social
convention that we feel obligated to not
only act but act quickly on what people
ask us to do ok we're happy we're
halfway through halfway through number 5
Parkinson's Law it's not actually a law
but it's the principle that I think
we've all experienced that
work expands to fill the time allotted
to it this is particularly true of
meetings
so most calendaring systems default a
meeting lengths to one hour how many of
you have ever been in a meeting
scheduled for an hour that really only
needed to happen for 20 minutes but
everyone you know stretches out the time
for the full hour anyway because you got
the room booked you got all the people
in the room might as well use it but it
turns out this is actually a huge waste
of time if you add up humility all these
hour-long meetings that really should
have been half hour meetings and it's
very hard to have the discipline to stop
a meeting when it's done and not when
the next person kicks you out of the
meeting room number six the planning
fallacy this is an effect that was first
discovered or first written about in
1979 by firstly and Kahneman the
favorite famous behavioral economists
and it refers to our systematic
underestimation of how long things take
turns out we apply an optimism bias
whenever we're projecting how long it's
going to take for a project to complete
or for us to do even a simple individual
task and the reason for that is when
we're making a projection on how long a
project is going to take we have this
optimistic lens that everything is going
to go smoothly the entire time even
though no project in the history of
humanity has ever gone smoothly the
entire time it's just a different thing
that goes wrong each time so it's very
hard to reason about and how much how
off we are depends a lot based on the
circumstance and there's a bunch of
tricks you can use to try to be more
accurate at estimating but a good rule
of thumb is that projects will take
about double what we think they well
it's it's it's a good rule of thumb
that's been proven across a variety of
cases and the really particularly
depressing thing about the planning
fallacy is that even if you tell someone
right before they're about to make an
estimation of how long something is
going to take there's that we are
subject to this behavioral flaw they're
still going to underestimate how long
it's going to take because again they're
not going to see all the little things
that will go wrong that are abstracted
away when you have an optimistic and
rosy picture of what's going to happen
related to the under estimation of how
long things will take
is the overestimation of how available
we'll be in the future
so if I ask anyone of you can you spend
four hours with me this afternoon
meeting your saying no way that's crazy
I'm at a conference I'm super busy I've
got a bunch of meetings to do can't
possibly spend four hours with you if I
ask you can you spend four hours with me
over the week of July 20th
you'll look your account I said yeah
sure I've got four weeks on the week of
July 20th now in reality you're going to
be just as busy the week of July 20th if
you are now you just don't know what the
things are yet that you're going to be
busy with and the further we are in the
future the less and less concrete the
other obligations that are vying for our
time are so the more we underestimate
how busy we'll be that's how you end up
doing things like two years from now you
commit to a two-week long workshop and
the time you get there you can't imagine
how you ever would have permitted to
that because you clearly don't have
enough time to do it
last one
productive time so our cognitive
capacity varies throughout the day and
if you're like most people you're at
your most productive in the morning
between roughly 8 a.m. and 11 a.m.
usually like after you've had your first
cup of coffee before you get super
hungry for lunch and if you're like most
people if you're like me that's when
you're kind of rolling into the office
you're checking email catching up on the
news easing your way into the day and
then after lunch when we're all at our
least productive typically the post
lunch dip 1 to 2 p.m. you read you
actually to get your real work done and
try to buckle down but simply don't have
the energy to do so and that's because
we do a very poor job of recognizing how
our cognitive capacity changes
throughout the day and how to align the
cognitive capacity of our mental state
with the cognitive capacity required by
the tasks that we need to do so we
misuse our most precious hours pretty
much every morning so we add all this up
we get interrupted we procrastinate we
do things that are urgent but not
important we can't say no we waste a
bunch of time and meetings that should
have ended more quickly we
underestimated how long everything's
going to take we overestimate how much
time we have we misuse our most precious
hours today it's like not a shock that
people think that 50% of their time is
not going to their strategic priorities
and
it's a it's a bleak outlook it's kind of
a downer it feels a little bit hopeless
but now I'll turn it over to Ian and
IANS going to tell us about a bunch of
the features that we're building in
Google Calendar and into Gmail to take
into account all these behavioral
principles that make us naturally bad at
managing time and hopefully we can make
it better Thank You Jacob okay so let's
talk solutions the problems that Jacob
described probably aren't new to a lot
of you there's hundreds of books online
articles training courses about how to
manage your time but most of us are
still doing a poor job so clearly
reading a book on productivity is not
enough so how do we solve this the
renowned behavioral economist Dan Ariely
often says that like one of the biggest
lessons we've had from behavioral
economics is that decisions we make
shaped by the environment that we're in
a great example of this is from outside
the workplaces contribution to
retirement plans like 401 K s there's a
large body research that shows that most
people will only save enough during
their working life if by default
contributions to the plan out of their
pay packet happen automatically so we
think that the best way to help people
improve their time management behavior
is to change the environment they
operating in and that raises the
question at work which environment
should be changed to get the biggest
benefit and we think Gmail and calendar
key and that's not just because we work
on them to repeat the figures from
McKinsey that Jacob mentioned earlier
the average knowledge work is spending
almost three hours a day in which
environment in their email client and
take calendar so around 90% of the large
companies that use G suite today in
employee calendars are shared with the
entire organization that means anyone
can look and see when you're available
and schedule a meeting with you this is
a really powerful tool for collaboration
but it can have the unfortunate side
effect that people start to manage your
time for you and as Jacob said once that
meeting invited arrives we're not
actually very good as saying no
so first of all I'm going to look at
some of the tools that we already have
in Gmail and calendar that will help you
and then I'm going to talk about the
future things we haven't released yet
that we're thinking about as new ways to
do this
okay so Priority Inbox it's been around
for a while many of you may have seen
this it was one of the early
intelligence features that we put into
Gmail back in 2010 and surprise mbox
uses a variety of signals to work out
which emails are likely important to you
and it shows these at the top separately
from all the other emails so what kind
of signals for example we look at who
you email to the most because emails
coming to you from those people are
likely important to you and we also look
at which emails you read which emails
you open which emails you reply to and
we can set it your mail similar to those
more important than the kind of emails
that you typically skip over and so what
all of that means is when you open Gmail
you're looking at the important stuff
with fewer distractions that can lead to
procrastination and there's also fewer
interruptions because you can set your
phone to buzz only when it's one of
these priority emails that arriving not
the rest and we have another tool in the
product today there's also around
elevating important emails and that's
tabbed inbox and it's ideal if you want
more control than Priority Inbox gives
you about how your email is divided up
particularly if you subscribe to a lot
of forums or if you get a lot of updates
from systems like workflow systems or
project management systems and tabbed
inbox automatically categorizes the
email so there's forums like Google
Groups there's updates like an invoice
coming in to your approval and then
there's a primary inbox which is usually
stuff from real people and like Priority
Inbox
this reduces distractions and makes it
easier to batch up those email sessions
into fewer larger sessions changing
tanks slightly and one of the reasons
people like allow themselves to get
distracted by non-emergent emails is
because they keep them around in their
inbox because they're scared that if
they don't then they'll forget about
them and they'll drop the ball and they
won't follow up
so we introduced the snooze feature
which will let you hide an email until a
future time or until you're on a future
locate location and that gets it out of
the way it doesn't give you the Contras
native load of having to remember to get
back to it instead we'll bump it to the
top of your inbox when that time or
place arrives so you can't miss it
and snoozing is available in the inbox
client which longside Gmail works well
for a variety of different workflows
including the zero inbox approach so
let's take a look at calendar now Jacob
talked about the the one hour meetings
we don't really need to be one hour so
what if you just had shorter meetings
well when you start using Google
Calendar in G suite today the default
length length for meetings is one hour
maybe we should change that but you can
set it to anything you like you can set
it to 10 minutes 15 minutes 30 minutes
what have you now I'm not saying that
you should make every meeting 10 minutes
long although it would be nice if that
was actually possible but by using the
power of default you can change the
environment so that your default of say
15 minutes makes it less work to shed
you a short meeting than it does
schedule long meeting so that's a pretty
simple hack to help reduce your meeting
load but we've also been working on some
more sort of complex problems and
solutions in particular how can we help
people spend more time focusing on long
term productive tasks despite this
tendency to become distracted and
procrastinate so let me quickly talk
about a study that was published in the
British Journal of health psychology a
few years ago and it was about how do
you get people to exercise more
frequently so there were three groups of
participants in this study and the first
group in the control group which is
people in their natural state just let
them do what they want around 38% of the
participants did exercise at least once
a week and so the question is how can we
get more people to do exercise so the
first thing they did is they took second
group they called the motivation group
and they tried to motivate them they
gave them a brochure on why exercise is
good for you they talked to them about
coronary heart disease and how tell
really unpleasant this is and how
exercise can actually help overcome
burrs and so you'd think that you would
get a positive outcome from this but
guess what you didn't in fact there was
a slight drop in the number of
participants in that group exercising at
least once a week however there was a
third group the intention group and in
this group the participants were asked
to commit a day and a time when you will
do your exercise next week and the week
after and so on and here the impact was
massive there we go
we actually saw that no in that study
they saw that 91% of participants were
exercising at least once a week and
that's a 160 percent increase over the
control so when we think about this in a
work context what does it tell us like
being motivated is not on its own enough
you're motivated right you all want to
do a great job at work you all want to
have an impact none of you want to get
fired but that on its own is not enough
to overcome these cognitive failures
that get in the way of how we spend our
time well however scheduling can make a
difference
the problem is scheduling everything
that you're going to do into your
calendar is actually hard work and so
many people even when they know about
this they don't do that extra worth of
scheduling so what we decided to do was
build a feature into the Google Calendar
product called gills and this is about
taking the work out of scheduling time
for these long term goals and we
launched it almost a year ago basically
you tell calendar what you want to do
how long you want to do it for and how
often you want to do it and calendar
takes care of setting up the sessions by
automatically blocking out time on your
calendar so how do we find good times
for you to do this if all you're telling
us is how frequently you want to
exercise or how frequently you want to
spend focus time so we start by picking
times that in general make sense for
everyone for example if it's a round
focused productive time in the morning
we obviously look at what's in your
calendar already because we wouldn't be
helping you if we shed your time over
and
meeting and then the system learns over
time so for example we shake if we
scheduled every Tuesday at 6 p.m. for
you to go running and you always check
that off as done as done we know it
works for you and we'll keep scheduling
event but on the other hand if we put
productive time for coding into your
calendar every Wednesday morning
and you keep moving it to Tuesday and
Thursday then we'll learn that Wednesday
isn't good and start scheduling it on
the other days now we designed goals to
work with a broad range of different
types exercises they've a popular but we
also see quite a lot of people using it
for work centric goals like having a
daily block for planning in the calendar
or focus time like the coding example
you can see here so this sort of takes
the effort out of doing them the
scheduling so you don't have to do it
manually does it still have the desired
effect of getting you to commit more and
it turns out that yes it does and
pleased to say so last summer after we
launched we ran an eight-week 95
participant study with people using this
feature and by the end of it 74% said
that it was helping them to meet their
goals and perhaps more importantly on
average participants for spending 30%
more time on their goals at the end of
the study than they were at the
beginning and we also saw a big increase
in the actual like amount of time people
were spending so as you can see from
this chart there was a 100% increase in
the number of participants who were
spending four or more hours a week on
what they described as their most
important goals so great we think it
works ok so let's move on to the future
I've just taken you through some of the
things that are in the product today you
can use it right now
and I want to take you through some
sorts of explorations how we're thinking
about improving the product in the
future now we're really excited about
these ideas we're excited to tell you
about them we'd love to get feedback
from you but please remember that
explorations they're not committed
features so they might not end up in the
product in the form that you're about to
see they might not end up in the product
at all that caveat aside let's
have a look at what we're thinking about
for email so priority inbox and tabbed
inbox are good at getting rid of the
clutter but for very busy email inboxes
there's still a lot of emails in there
and it's hard for people to know which
email to look at first so the highlights
exploration which you can see here
builds on Priority Inbox by more
accurately elevating the most important
and urgent emails and it does this by
using NLP to actually look at what is
the content of the email and so for
example it could elevate an email where
someone has requested a response today
particularly if that's also someone that
we know is important to you and in
addition to that it actually shows a
rationale which you can see in gray
above each email explaining why we've
elevated that so you can eat more easily
make a decision about whether you want
to act on that email now or later and
working together with this we have a
second exploration the limited
notifications exploration and this is
about getting fewer interruptions by
only notified being notified when those
most important emails arrive and it's
not just about looking at the most
important emails but it also takes your
context into account what are you doing
so if you're on a meeting for example or
if it's outside your normal working
hours then the threshold the bar
actually buzzing your phone is going to
be higher than if you're at work and not
doing anything in particular
changing text slightly so we talked
about snooze and how snooze could help
you make sure that you didn't drop the
ball and forget to reply but snooze is
kind of manual you still have to
actually decide when you're going to
snooze that email to and that you want
to lose that email so in this in this
exploration again we use NLP to
automatically detect which emails are
requesting a response from you or where
you have requested a response to an
email you've sent and if there's been no
risk no response in either direction for
a certain period of time we'll bump
those at the top of your inbox again
telling you hey
you know you haven't replied for three
days or perhaps you want to follow this
up because the other person hasn't
replied for some amount of time okay so
let's go back to calendar so we talked a
lot about the fact that we're bad at
saying no so what if calendar said no so
that you didn't have to so in this
exploration we've been thinking about
what if we let users specify a limit on
how much time they want to put spend on
meetings each week 15 hours in this case
I'm essentially taking that pie chart of
time use that Jacob was talking about
and making it an integral part of the
product so what could we do well
essentially we could change the
scheduling environment not for you but
for all of your colleagues who try to
schedule time with you so if they try
and set up a meeting with you that would
violate your limits we can push back
before that invite that's gone out and
we can actually tell them that hey
there's a cost of scheduling with you
right because you're busy and we can
provide a low-friction way out by
suggesting times you can see that here
in the middle screenshot where you're
both available where you've both got
time where you're not violating the
limits and if they really want to have
that meeting with you anyway because
maybe it is urgent we nudge them into
actually justifying themselves to you
rather than just sending an anonymous
invite and leaving all the work of
saying no and justifying not going to
you okay finally we thought about what
would goals look like if it was focused
on making sure that you were you were
allocating enough focus time to do
productive work so we thought about a
couple of things in this exploration
obviously we've talked a lot about
making sure that time is scheduled in
the morning and making sure we get other
things out of the way so you can have
your focus time in the morning we looked
at having a do not disturb mode there
could be even more aggressive at getting
rid of disruptions like for example
stopping hangouts chat notifications
from happening happening in addition
when we talk to people who currently
block out time manually on calendar to
make time today or use the Guild's
feature
a common complaint was that their
colleagues ignore the block let's say oh
it's a work block I can schedule over
that because they're not in a meeting so
again we want to change the scheduling
environment so we're calling out the
fact that you're going to interrupt
someone but there's a cost to doing that
and here's some times which are more
appropriate for having a meeting rather
than doing focused work okay so that's
some of the ways we're thinking about
changing Gmail and calendar in the
future I hope this has been interesting
and a good use of your time
in conclusion we think that when it
comes to managing your time better the
environment is key so if you only
remember three things from today this is
what we'd recommend first of all use the
Google mail and calendar clients on your
phone in your laptop as well as on phone
and tablet as well as on the laptop it
will help you today and it's going to
help you even more in the future
secondly unless your role at work is
entirely reactive block out a healthy
dose of make time in the calendar in the
mornings so that you can get productive
work done and tell your colleagues
because if you all respect each other's
make time you're going to be more
effective and more productive so with
that good luck with time management
thank you very much for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
you